hello youtube how's your day going it's
going well done
so i saw someone in the youtube comments
um on the trailer for this say
basically like forget infinity war this
is the greatest crossover event of our
time
wow i mean i mean do you agree you got
to agree with that
i'm not going to disagree we're not
going to disagree
we're gonna we're gonna just let it air
on the 24th of july
see how you feel about it all right let
the world decide for themselves let the
world decide for themselves
what was it like getting getting a
chance to mix up these two casts
together it looks like i mean
from what we've seen it looks like an
absolute blast was it a blast on set
doing this
oh yeah yeah it was go ahead nope nope
um it was it was awesome because like
raven and i are friends
lisa i mean and then the kids everybody
had somebody their age which was so cool
with this
like everybody had somebody so um to see
those kids become
friends and hang out and then their
characters see them together it was a
really cool experience but
um the off-screen stuff was definitely
my favorite
the on-screen's great but i really wish
there was another camera
raven are we gonna get we're gonna get a
behind-the-scenes uh documentary on this
no no that's not happening it's in the
vault that's just for us to know let's
just say
the behind the scenes chemistry is the
reason
this might be the most epic crossover on
disney channel
and it was like being one of the
executive producers on this as well
um executive producing in general has
probably been one of my favorite things
with this new
uh journey into the industry and
directing
um miranda's directing now as well so
we were able to during this crossover
talk about
our versions of things how we work as
directors and how we
will further our
uh index of directorial skills
while watching a master do his work um
the director of this episode was
absolutely amazing and
being able to i know you asked me about
ep but
with such a big episode i kept my mouth
shut
there's so many cooks in the kitchen
there's so many producers so many notes
from disney channel from
raven's home from bunked they didn't
need an extra voice sometimes you gotta
know when to sit down
so i sat down and miranda and i got to
talk about other things along with lisa
and like she said everybody had their uh
same age bracket of friends to talk to
so i actually had an easy time as a new
pee i didn't really do that
i'm nice can you two talk about what
it's like to
not only be on set with um friends like
people that you actually like and want
to hang out with
but also people who you are able to
support
professionally you can teach each other
things and also learn from each other
um and and give each other a step up
you know what i mean in this industry
yeah no it was great to to watch
everybody learn from each other like you
were saying i mean we have different
types of shows so um those worlds
colliding
and seeing how you know this set
operates art that operates
how the kids you know prepare their
lines or how they deliver their lines
how you know one cast rehearses versus
the other cast it was all a learning
experience and
um to do it within your home was really
cool
um and to feel comfortable to learn and
to feel like it was a safe place to
ask questions or to make jokes when
something was funny because sometimes
you go somewhere new and you're like
i have something really funny to say but
i should
you know to watch each other and learn
um i missed the last part of your
sentence yeah we must
the last could you repeat the very last
part we you're here
out there just a second yeah okay okay i
just said it was really cool to watch
everybody
learn and be comfortable enough to learn
um
yeah amongst people their own age
younger older i learned something from
everybody and uh
in their own process and for me
i have to be i'm gonna be like the mama
side of it i know that
miranda is a wonderful leader
on her set and teaches these kids all of
the information that she does and i try
to do the same on my set
so i told um my kids i was like
now when you go on this set we're gonna
learn we're gonna regurgitate everything
we learn right i'm not gonna have to say
anything right
he's such a mom and they're like grown
they have their own moms
and so it for me it was a learning
experience to just
calm down and trust the fact that
they've learned
from our years together and me talking
so much in their ear
and they did you know they everybody was
so sweet to each other so cordial so
respectful
um they really were
little professionals and it made me so
proud to know
that they soaked up the information um
from the people they've worked with in
the past
and then you know practiced what they
preached on stage
yeah that's awesome it sounds like um
[Music]
such an amazing set to have been on does
that make you think
well we're going to just have to do this
again
i mean there is always time after corona
you never
know um i definitely want to work with
miranda
again um as us as
adults that's something that we are
really striving for
and it would be amazing to bring all the
kids together themselves
you know who knows a little spin-off
here a little little twirl there a
little dab there like you never know
what can happen
yeah i think everybody would like to see
that
well certainly whoever wrote that
comment on youtube will be like yes
[Laughter]
we are living of course in the time of
corona how has how have you guys been
raven how has newlywed life
been for you it's been so much um
i've been getting my life i've been so
happy
uh i've you know i've had my time i i
don't want to sound
um ignorant i know what's going on in
the universe but
i have to be honest i'm in like this
really long honeymoon phase
and it doesn't end until corona ends
so i'm good right now yeah well i gotta
say thank you so much
for uh for your time to see you i've got
to wrap this up but this has been a lot
of fun
um and you know like i said we'll get
the second part
when this is all over okay yes all right
thanks
you